hi
girls and guys can probably both relate
to this video when a girl is getting
ready for either a date or to go out and
there's a guy waiting for her nothing is
more annoying to the girl than the guy
getting frustrated because she's taking
so long and there's nothing more
annoying to the guy because the girl is
taking so freaking long to get ready and
he has no idea what the heck she is
doing in the bathroom my favorite thing
is when they'll come to the bathroom and
they'll just take a little look see what
you're doing and just look at you like
they've spotted a freaking alien
spacecraft
it is you it is your face while you're
trying to put on makeup and when you
actually try to explain what you're
doing they just won't really understand
now once you're done with makeup they
think that you're done how do you think
this hair that is not dry gets dry
your hair's dried they think that you're
done nope we're not done yet there's
either hair curling or hair
straightening maybe we'll skip the hair
straightener for today we still
sometimes straighten the straight hair
we leave now no now we need to find an
outfit you'd think that finding an
outfit was probably one of the easiest
things in the world because you guys are
like holy crap you girls have so many
pairs of shoes and so many different
types of clothing why can't you just
find one to demystify some of the
mysteries that goes on in the bathroom i
decided to film myself putting on my
makeup and doing my hair i apologize on
behalf of all of the females in the
world to you guys who have to wait for
us to get ready we're sorry but uh we're
not really that sorry